بي تي اس وبلاك بينك فرق غنائيه كوريه
مكتسحه العالم ومن اشهر يعني بخلينا نقول
يعني مثلا انه من امتسحين العالم وهم من
اهم الفرق في عالم الكيبوب لكن الان في
فرقه جديده نسبيا في هذا العالم هي ايضا
كمان ب 9 لتحقيق نفس النجاح والانتشار حول
العالم هذه الفرقه اسمها وبدات نشاطها في
20 21 وهي مكونه من 11 بنت
[موسيقى]
مثل ما شفته في الصور او المقاطع اللي
عرضناها يعني كانها فرقه غنائيه مثل غيرها
لكن المفاجاه الحقيقيه هي هويه اعضائها
فالفرقه ما هي الا فرقه افتراضيه او
المغنيات اللي شايفينهم هدولي مو حقيقيين
هدول ابطال انخلقوا عن طريق برمجيه ذكاء
الاصطناعي والفرقه عملتها شركه اسمها
باريس
واللي معنا ببساطه تعليم الكمبيوتر يعمل
البني ادميه او يعمل ايه البني ادمين
يعملوه هذه شركه قررت تعمل الفرقه وراحت
مستخدم التقنيات الديب فريك اولا وعمله
101 او نموذج استخدم فيهم صفات عامه
معروفه فيهم نجوم الكيبوب انهم مثلا جد-
ابرياء الاذكياء كيوت وبعدين خلوا
الجمهوري يصوت على الوجوه هذه وجابوا مص
وخلوهم يبنوا على الوجوه اللي اخذت اعلى
نسبه الصور والفرقه الان لها حسابات على
منصات على الاف او عليها الاف المتابعين
ويعني مثلها مثل الحسابات النجوم بالضبط
واغانيها بتنزل اليوتيوب وعليها ملايين
المشاهدات الاغنيه اللي شايفينها نازله من
شهر بس وعليها سته ونصف مليون مشاهده يعني
فرقه زي اي فرقه ثانيه لها معجبينها
ومتابعينها وكله يعني اما بالنسبه اللي
الغناه في الاصوات اللي سمعتوها هي
الاصوات المغنيين حقيقيين مذاكره اصطناعي
والشركه بتقول انه في الفيديوهات هذه اكثر
تحديدا جزئيه لسه محتاج الشغل لانه اكثر
شيء لو ركز فيه المشاهد هينتبه انه الفم
مو ماشي مع الغنى بالضبط ليش الشركه عملت
فرقه افتراضيه بتقول لي لانها شايف
المستقبل
وللعلمي انا حتى انه كل واحده من اعضاء
الفريق تعمل لهم اصوله يعني ما منفرد كده
ويسيروا وينزل سنجلز ويعني زي العادي
الفرق البني ادمين متعودين عليهم
الطبيعيين يعني هذا غير شويه شغلهم طبعا
كمان في الاعلانات وعلى السوشل ميديا كمان
مفاجاه ثانيه اكتشفناها كمان انه هذه مو
اول فرقه كوريه فيها اعضاء افاتارز ففي
فرقه ثانيه اسمها اسبا وهذه اعضاءها اربع
بني ادمين واربع افاتارس